ja schönen guten tag alles zusammen hat
keine ahnung wo ich hier gelandet bin
aber ich finde es ganz cool
es geht ab und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja ich bin grad nicht
in köln
sonst hätte ich das video jetzt in
meinem zimmer gemacht sondern hier also
ein bisschen auf dem land ja und ich
hatte irgendwie überhaupt keinen bock
dieses video in meinem zimmer zu drehen
und bin einfach mal raus gegangen kurz
hin habe ich gesagt ich war hier glaube
ich vorher noch nie auf diesem weg aber
ist auch scheißegal und zwar muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen habe ich heute morgen
erst dieses video gesehen was in den
youtube trends auf platz eins ist das
ist youtube hat ja bald nicht mehr geben
wird und so weiter hat mir das auch halb
angeguckt fand sogar gar nicht mal
schlecht also das video war schon
relativ informativ und das haben wir
schon mega mega viele andere youtuber ja
ein video dazu gemacht und sind
irgendwie darauf eingegangen und haben
darauf hingewiesen dass sich dass jeder
mal anschauen soll und dass youtube bald
weg sein wird und so also ich habe heute
morgen wirklich diese ganzen videos
gesehen
ich muss nur sagen dass ich mir nur eins
angeguckt hat und er keine ahnung ich
habe mir gedacht ich komm' machst du
heute mal auch ein video zu dem thema
wir haben auch nicht viele leute auf
instagram schrieben jo alex bewusst
sagst du zu diesem artikel 13 und das
ein hochsitz kann ich da hochwald wird
dein youtube-kanal gelöscht so weit gut
genug drumherum gelabert ihr habt es
wahrscheinlich schon gelesen in diesem
video geht es um fünf gründe warum
youtube eigentlich so ich bin mir zu 100
prozent sicher dass es nicht in
deutschland gelöscht wird
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich hatte in
der uni zwar schon einige rechts welcher
auch medienrecht aber da sind wir gar
nicht auf solche sachen eingegangen
deswegen was so rechtliche sachen angeht
rechtliche paragrafen und so weiter habe
ich irgendwie ja relativ wenig ahnung
von aber ich habe einfach mal so ein
bisschen nachgedacht und ich finde auch
logisch nachgedacht und habe fünf gründe
herausgestellt auf die halt eigentlich
auch jeder von euch hätte kommen können
glaube ich natürlich kann es sein dass
man die gründe vielleicht widerlegen
kann mit irgendetwas ich würde
allerdings auch nichts gekommen
falls ihr da irgendwas wissen schreibt
es gerne in die kommentare
also ich will nicht sagen dass das alles
zu 100 prozent richtig ist aber wir
fangen jetzt einfach mal an und zwar
erst mal kurz mit der definition von
artikel 13 es gibt ja noch den artikel
11 aber der bezieht sich finde ich nicht
so wirklich auf youtube also eigentlich
dreht sich alles für das video um den
artikel 13
internet anbieter müssen sicherstellen
dass inhalte die von nutzern auf ihren
plattform hochgeladen werden im einklang
mit dem urheberrecht stehen falls die
zustimmung der rechteinhaber fehlt
müssen die anbieter die bereitstellung
der fraglichen inhalte auf ihren
plattformen verhindern maßnahmen zur
erkennung des urheberrechts und
effektive content sind effektive content
erkennungs technologien die angemessen
eingesetzt werden sollen youtube hat was
das angeht schon das beste also besser
geht's nicht und das ist ja immer noch
nicht zu 100 prozent ja alles abgedeckt
also es sind immer noch lücken im system
so dann kommen wir jetzt zu begründen
warum youtube nicht gespürt und da bin
ich mir auch wirklich wie eben schon
gesagt sehr sicher youtube gehört ja zu
google
die sitzen ja in amerika und wenn jetzt
die eu beschließt dass dieser artikel
wirklich so in kraft tritt oder dieses
gesetz und ja alle kanäle jetzt zum
beispiel aus deutschland frankreich und
so weiter gelöscht werden könnte youtube
eigentlich sagen gut das ist zwar bei
euch in europa so bei uns in amerika
gibt es das gesetz allerdings nicht und
lässt und hat einfach alle kanäle über
amerikanisches recht laufen das gleiche
bezieht sich natürlich dann auch auf
facebook instagram das sind ja alles so
soziale netzwerke wo ja die user den
erfolg ausmachen oder vor allem halt den
umsatz ausmachen und dann könnte die eu
jetzt sagen ja dann sperren wir halt
einfach so webseiten in deutschland mich
meinen aufgrund der digitalisierung kann
man ja auf alles mögliche zu greifen
innerhalb von sekunden auch was in
amerika hochgeladen wird was sonst
nirgendwo auf der welt passiert und wenn
halt also webseiten wie youtube und so
weiter gelöscht werden schränkt das ja
sehr die meinungsfreiheit ein die ja in
deutschland sehr wichtig ist und das war
ja schon so ein krasser
schritt in die vergangenheit zurück wenn
man plötzlich ja nicht mehr so auf
youtube zugreifen kann oder diese
website halt einfach gesperrt werde ich
meine in nordkorea glaube ich es auch
youtube gesperrt
und ja so kommen wir zum punkt immer
zwei ganz kurz und knapp ja schon wieder
viel zu viel
stellt euch vor youtube wird jetzt am 10
juni 2009 10 ja in deutschland nicht
mehr verfügbar sein und die großen
youtuber die er davon leben würden sich
gegen werden das heißt eure lieblings
youtuber wie ich oder magie baby julian
beim sonst war es die sind natürlich
noch mal 58 groß wie ich sie würden
sagen ja wir sind jetzt morgen
arbeitslos ihr könnt unsere videos nicht
mehr gucken stellt euch mal vor was dann
in deutschland los wäre ich meine das
ist auf der einen seite auch das was
youtube vielleicht relativ unberechenbar
mal wenn so eine 5 millionen youtube bin
einfach eine meinung raus weil hat die
eine million menschen übernehmen
vielleicht ist das nicht immer gut aber
wenn dann nicht nur diese eine youtube
sondern ganz viele große youtuber zehn
millionen kids in deutschland mit dieser
meinung beeinflussen stellt euch mal vor
also zehn millionen zehn- bis 15-jährige
gehen in deutschland auf die straßen und
demonstrieren für baby also ganz
unlogisch ist das ja nicht weil diese
jüngere leute sind ja viel stärker zu
beeinflussen und auch viel schneller als
ältere leute das soll jetzt auch gar
nichts negatives euch gegenüber sein
weil ich weiß ja auch dass hier viele
jugendliche zu gucken gut kommen wir zum
nächsten punkt das internet ist so groß
und es fließen milliarden an
werbegeldern in dieses system und da
muss man ja in deutschland auch einiges
an steuern zahlen und ich glaube wenn
diese großen internetriesen wie facebook
youtube instagram und so weiter weg
während gegen ja eine menge steuern
flöten und ich glaube mit diesen summen
sollte man auch nicht passen weil das
ist schon gar nicht mal wenn keine
ahnung ob daran keiner denkt oder ob ich
da falsch denke ich könnte gerne in die
kommentare schreiben
also habe ich am anfang gesagt
vielleicht glaube ich gerade auch
kompletten bullshit aber es ist halt
einfach meine meinung als repräsentant
dieser branche kommen hinzu punkt 4 was
eigentlich aber sogar nur eine notlösung
ist und keineswegs der perfekte weg wäre
aber wenn diese urheberrechtsgesetze in
kraft treten sollten und youtube
wirklich alle kanäle löschen muss die
nicht von irgendwelchen großen konzernen
betrieben werden wäre das natürlich
nicht die optimale lösung
aber es führt dazu dass youtube
weiterhin bestehen bleibt ich meine das
fernsehen ist davon nicht betroffen und
wenn youtube wird sagt gut dann nehmen
wir halt in europa halt in allen ländern
die davon betroffen sind diese großen
youtube oder alle kanäle die eine hohe
relevanz haben bei uns unter vertrag das
problem ist dann kann natürlich nicht
mehr jeder hingehen und sagen hey ich
glaub mal kurz ein youtube video hoch
weil das dann auch nur noch diese leute
können die bei youtube sozusagen unter
vertrag sind das sind dann auch nicht
mehr millionen von leuten es sind
trotzdem einzelne person die noch das
machen können was sie möchten und was
der vorteil von ihm ist man hat als
youtube dann im überblick darüber und
kann halt auch wenn es natürlich blöd
ist alle videos bevor sie online gehen
kurz abnehmen halt auf urheberrecht
überprüfen wobei sich die meisten
größeren youtuber was sowas angeht ja
auch auskennen und da aufpassen
dann hätten wir zwar nicht mein youtube
wie wir es kennen aber wir hatten noch
einen youtube was sein ähnlich wie das
fernsehen ist allerdings ein bisschen
auf jüngere weise im fünften punkt habe
ich gerade irgendwie vergessen es ist
jetzt blöd deswegen würde ich einfach
mal sagen schreib ihr doch mal einen
fünften punkt oder einen fünften grund
in die kommentare
und lasst eure meinung zum thema da ich
finde das ist auf jeden fall eine sache
der man aufmerksamkeit schenken sollte
weil wir wollen ja alle noch fleißig
youtube gucken und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht machst du mal das video dazu
mit diesen gründen die mir eingefallen
sind und gibt es nicht das wider was eh
schon alle gesagt haben ja das war's mit
diesem video abonniere nicht vergessen
und was sich zum schluss vielleicht auch
noch sagen könnte die abstimmung für
diese artikel 11 und 13
ich glaube ich irgendwie schon am 12
september erfolg aber jetzt wurde erst
darauf aufmerksam gemacht und plötzlich
ist der aufschrei riesig ich bin mir
sicher dass youtube oder google als
weltkonzern da irgendeine lösung parat
haben wird welcher auch immer und bin
auf jeden fall mal gespannt aber der
festen überzeugung dass ich noch so
lange youtube videos machen kann wie ich
weiß schon was man also das was mit dem
video das dann nach oben da also eine
kür
aber ich bin wirklich richtig auf dem
land und ich fahre jetzt wieder nach
hause
auch ganz schön kalt